i feel the same way about knowledge i  think ether is nod's greatest right i  hate that beat you hate to be yeah that  beat is [ __ ] fire ron brows what's  your favorite district  ever  um the [ __ ] in you by common  favorite or greatest my favorite  favorite favorite not greatest favorite  i think the greatest just hit him up  that's probably the greatest yeah no  vaseline is crazy that's a tough one  my favorite dish record man  um honestly the greatest is probably  back to back though cause that still  gets played on the radio and in the club  yeah it's different too that's a monster  um  it's am i just like a record for  playability  favorite dish record damn that's some  good dish you know what i won't lie and  uh this probably gonna be some [ __ ] but  dollars in a sense dj quick oh man  they said eiht should i continue you  left out the g because the g ain't in  you  that record was fire  fire